let me let me let me ask you guys this
question and then we'll bring up this
story uh so first we have a story i'll
just show this real quick what we're
gonna get into trevor noah ripping joe
biden's from a few days ago but um i
think it's fascinating to see that even
people like bill maher and trevor noah
who would never give donald trump a
single good day not even after he took
out the leader of isis they still they
called him an austere scholar they would
not give trump the credit
you know
something seems to be changing but right
now we're dealing with a president in
joe biden that i believe could be
presiding over the collapse of u.s
dominance around the world the end of
u.s imperialism whatever you want to
call it and you know ian you mentioned
in just just previously that you'd
rather have an authoritarian psychopath
who's making the country work than
someone like biden but no let's let's
let's explore that i mean
is it is it better to have someone who
cracks the whip but fixes the problem or
someone who sits back as everything
bursts into flames and falls apart who
is also also who also happens to be an
authoritarian psychopath on top of that
well then it's obvious
my patience is running thin either
extremism in either of those directions
is a bad thing i would think because you
don't want someone so authoritarian
psycho like hitler that will just like
mobilize and take in concourse but you
don't want someone that's so checked out
like biden that he can't say words
properly or even give a state of the
union he couldn't do it he just gave a
campaign speech he couldn't give a state
of the union because he didn't you might
not even know what the state of the
union is he was like slurring his words
the whole time it was actually he got
very sad
did you see the bingo thing we did luke
no we uh uh
we had like a bingo cards
for the state of the union and one of
them was like if joe biden uses a fake
word
but he kept slurring so much and
stuttering that would like that counts
does that count as a fake word or not
you know saying like to
trade to traders were like
meanwhile when trump did that like he
was tweeting and he there was some
obvious auto complete and they made fun
of him for like three years
yeah that was great but the problem is
really i mean biden can't speak first of
all trump had an odd manner of speaking
it wouldn't be hard to find someone that
could just speak in normal english and
they managed to not do that but if biden
totally keels over and we've got kamala
harris she can't speak either i mean
just being able to speak english is like
the lowest
possible qualification yeah she's got
the nervous we talked about this before
the show a little bit like the
nervousness where like if i let myself
be who i really am i'm going to say
something wrong i'm going to put and
that's the thing is we don't know who
any of these people are biden is clearly
not in charge of the country but who is
and it's the same thing with kamala who
is behind the scenes here's my favorite
quote from kamala
it is time for us to do what we have
been doing and that time is every day
every day it is time for us to agree
that there are things and tools that are
available to us to slow this thing down
it sounds like the arthur theme song the
title of this article from thecut.com is
come again come
on this just can't talk either it was
like that article was like trump did
something in a bathtub no one knows
about maybe but we don't have any other
oh no an elevator yeah an elevator you
ever see that article from the
huffington post no uh some trump did
something somewhere
what he did we don't know what it what
you know who was there we're not sure
but it's the holy grail and i'm like
wait what
that's hysterical well but even this
article right trevor noah ripping donald
trump
or i'm sorry ripping joe biden and
saying donald trump would have been
better is really significant because to
these people on the left trump is
literally hitler and even if he doesn't
necessarily feel that way his audience
sure does so for him to be willing to
say let me give points to the person who
my side has literally been referring to
as hitler for years and years because
the current president is doing so poorly
doesn't really say good things for joe
biden so let me let me let me quick just
jump back to this yahoo story right
trevor noah rips biden over saudi uae
phone snub report would have never
happened to donald trump you uh uh so
this is like finally now i'm surprised
to hear this from trevor noah
i want to show you why this is so
surprising we have this tweet from
huffington post my favorite a tape might
exist of trump doing something in an
elevator though exactly where that
somewhere is and what that something
might be no one in media can say that's
because no one in media seems to have
seen the tape or is even confident it
exists
this is
trevor as an investigative journalist
how do you feel about that headline i
think we might see a next pull out
surprise winner yeah yeah yeah how much
wanna bet they did win one i'm sure look
at that image of trump's face too this
is amazing
is that someone chasing him in trump
tower and they're like hey trump trump
and then he wouldn't look at him but
they took the picture anyway yeah so so
it's crazy that
in their hysteria they created an idea
of something that didn't exist they
didn't define what that idea was
this article really does embody we hate
trump for no reason
now you have these liberal pundits
coming out and being like
maybe trump you know wasn't so bad
so what really really just man i'm so my
i got a headache and everything and i'm
just like
all these people that were screaming
we have to stop donald trump he's an
egomaniac he's a fascist and now we are
dealing with quite possibly the worst
administration we've ever seen in the
history of this country maybe you can
argue woodrow wilson was worse for a lot
of reasons maybe buchanan pre-civil war
but uh right now
the u.s
there's a lot of things happening in
terms of soaring gas prices inflation
manipulation lies
escalating war you know i saw a leftist
post on facebook they said if
they were basically saying why didn't we
enact a no-fly zone before the war even
started when it was ukrainian airspace
and ukraine had the right to agree to
the united states and say we could do it
that would have forced russia to break
our
you know red line and i thought it was
an interesting point because if joe
biden knew all this was happening if
ukraine and everybody knew russia was
going to do this then we could have gone
in and secured it before the war even
started and it would have been incumbent
upon russia to be the ones to aggress
against nato not the other way around
you look at afghanistan and bagram air
force base all of it is basically just
failures of entail intelligence failures
to act or do anything that would prevent
war now i suppose you can argue they
must really really want war but when i
kind of look at everything the binding
administration has done i'm thinking you
know what maybe they're just
maybe maybe incompetent is an
understatement yeah well i mean drawing
a line in the sand there and stating a
no-fly zone prior to russia invading
regardless of whether you think that
would be a good idea as an idea which
would require actual decision-making and
leadership and he's not capable of that
he's the worst
the worst military commander i've ever
seen in the united
of his age is states his senility but
the upside is he should be more moored
to the democratic party before it took
this illiberal turn which is very very
dangerous where they're just kind of you
know they've turned against the first
amendment they've turned against
neutrality under the law the younger
generation has but bill maher
what he's saying is no surprise because
he's a guy of a certain age he remembers
the democratic party of 20 years ago
which is a reasonable party
biden knows full well he is he is a part
of that party and yet he doesn't have
the spine to stand up against the uh the
young woke mop yeah when bill bill
crystal i don't know the guy personally
but he was a big part of like
orchestrating the iraq war with the bush
administration he's basically people
what people have told me is that all
those neocons now are just in the
democratic party they just
there's it's the war the war party
basically and whatever you want to slap
d or r on it doesn't matter because
they're all administrative states well
and it's interesting because people like
chain the cheneys i mean they're part of
the war party and now they're
essentially democrats or at least legend
list genie is yeah that's wild
yeah well i mean they see that that's a
party full of people who are much more
likely to comply with whatever you tell
them yeah
well joe biden's behavior really makes
me think that he's certainly not the one
pulling the strings which generally
makes me wonder what's actually going on
because it's obviously not kamala
because i've said this before on twitter
and i got roasted for it but i think
that she knows she's out of place she
knows she's out of her depth listening
to her explanation of the invasion of
ukraine she's like russia is a big
country in ukraine's a little country
and russia went into ukraine that's bad
i was like are you serious but she was
talking to a black radio station which
is like it's one of the most racist
things i've ever seen yeah i couldn't
make up my mind i was like either she's
being super racist or she just says no
ideas
yeah but is it is it easier i mean is it
simpler to just say no one has the
strings
you know yeah my view of gary has been
that joe biden is in charge but everyone
knows he's asleep
even trevor noah in that segment was
like biden's in bed by 4 p.m yeah so
it's hard for him to schedule phone
calls with saudi arabia who's eight
hours ahead i mean it's a good joke but
so is it like the chief of staff like
rob clayne or whatever is that the guy
that's running the country i know i
think i think they're all sitting at the
table and joe biden's sitting there and
they all sit down and they're like okay
joe you know what's going on and he's
like
turn it on a shot of pressure and then
like kamala looks at rob and they just
like
okay
uh so
what's the agenda and he's like oh come
on man yeah the president and then they
just get up and leave and they're like
well we have no agenda we have no plans
the president fell asleep let's go
bowling yeah exactly if the president
gives no orders they can do whatever
they want basically until they're told
to stop or there's nothing there's no
there's nothing there's no nucleus yeah
it is or at the very least it's a
damaged nucleus joe biden you know with
a super chat someone said uh kofi david
he says my kofi was my favorite word
until i witnessed the magic of true nana
shop at a pressure that's true that's
that's true i mean think about
trump had to accidentally tweet a word
and everyone went nuts biden actually
took the the energy to say a much much
longer and more absurd word
it's it's more than once too you have a
battle catheter yeah
what is that what is medical care i
don't know
man um yeah i mean he's not just an
empty suit he's worse than that yeah
he's really worse than that and there is
something very sad about the fact that
this country has become so divided and
har hyper partisan because of the
encroaching far leftism that has
hijacked the minds of the democratic
party many of the american people
especially as the right wing has started
moving to the left
and it's gotten to the point where you
don't even really get to consider
whether someone's going to be a good
leader when you elect them you're just
looking at their policies
and so the democrats were not concerned
with whether joe biden would be the
right person to leave this country they
just said well he's not trump and they
picked him on that basis there's a story
right now the white house called in a
bunch of tick-tockers yeah and
the big guns i feel bad for the tick
tockers there's like some 18 year old
woman who's got like 10 million
followers yeah and i watched her video
and she was just like gas is high
because vladimir putin and i'm like
she's literally just quoting jen sackey
yeah and i feel so bad for her because
she's clearly well intentioned like i'm
gonna help my followers she you know i
see these tick tockers and these are
people who do like entertainment content
if they're willing to take time out of
their day to actually address serious
political issues that's actually a
really good thing but when they're being
manipulated by the white house to push
lies to prop up a guy who's gutting the
system that they live under and making
their lives worse i'm like that that's
just they're willingly taking part in
propaganda yeah no but they don't know
better right so look we can say the path
the hell is paid with good intentions
but i think the issue is the you're
you're you're on tick tock you film
videos of you doing makeup and you know
hang out with your dog and you get 10
million followers or whatever and then
along comes who you think is the
authority who's got your best who's got
your back because you don't know better
and they're like here's what's happening
and you go i better tell my followers
about this so i can help them i can
respect the good intentions
i don't fault an 18 year old kid from be
for being lied to i blame the white
house for lying to them and manipulating
all of these young people what i think
is weird though is i assume these are
attempts to reach quote the youth and
these are young tick talkers and they're
just kind of echoing like what the man
tells you and i i thought you know
growing up
i thought part of being a young person
was being rebellious and uh they're just
kind of just regurgitating whatever the
government tells them to i wonder if
young people still have that spirit of
uh you know rebellion yeah i mean
some of them i mean maybe the reality is
most young people weren't rebellious
just some of them were the the people
who went on to become you know leaders
and and challenging the system
innovating and disrupting they were
rebels but i think most people probably
aren't they're probably just conformist
i wasn't very rebellious i had to learn
to rebel i had to kind of teach myself
how when i learned how corrupted the
system had become like in 2007 i was
like wow i really have to i can't just
live under this boot even though i'm
really wealthy do you guys remember when
casey neistat
endorsed hillary clinton oh
so yeah it's 2016. he's uh one of the
biggest youtubers he's got five and a
half million subs at the time now it's
way bigger and i think he's like
semi-retired i'm not sure he doesn't
really produce as much as he's used to
and he made a video where it's like his
channel is about travel and adventure
and then all of a sudden he's talking
about hillary clinton and he said it's
because
this election wasn't about politics it
was about one egomaniac and his quest
for power or something like that
and that hillary clinton was the only
person who could be trump and i was like
casey who told you that huh because
that's politics and you were lied to
and it's provable hillary clinton could
not beat trump she lost to him and it
was so bad they didn't try to bring her
back for round two she was in fact the
one person who could lose to trump
because i'm pretty sure they could have
brought in almost anybody and probably
beaten trump but hillary was absolutely
despised so they go to these influencers
people like casey who don't know
anything about politics and i don't i
don't mean that in any way
disrespectfully he's not a political guy
they tell him here's the thing and he
goes okay i'm gonna go say that and he
was completely and utterly wrong he's
come out later saying he was a mistake
and he shouldn't have done it and he's
right trump ended up being
actually a really good president
bad in some ways for sure nobody's
perfect
but setting a timeline for getting out
of afghanistan trying to get out of
syria best numbers of our lives in terms
of terms of
economics in 2016 and 2019 a lot of good
things under trump he was jammed up by
the the neocons and the neoliberal
establishment
they had scandal after scandal holding
him back tying his hands and he still
did some good things far from perfect
but pretty good way better than biden i
don't know what what uh what would have
happened with hillary but those ideas
were just wrong then we get the same
lies in 2020 when
these social media influencers came out
don't give a special shout out to people
like contra points
who said you have to vote for joe biden
do you regret saying that so now what
we're getting from the propaganda
machine is aren't you glad trump isn't
president why
even bill maher is saying it's a good
question why didn't putin invade ukraine
under trump
so no i think all of these people who
came out were like guys look i'm a
leftist and i don't like the
establishment but you have to vote for
joe biden it's like there's no logic
there at all because if you really
wanted the system to collapse donald
trump was the ball in the china shop if
you really wanted something good you
want a repeat of trump's economic plan
that helped everybody with a good
economy there was literally no reason to
vote for a war mongering corrupt despot
like joe biden and they did and now gas
prices record highs inflation four four
decade highs every single month
wholesale consumer prices up 10
escalation of war our southern border in
shambles
everything's worse more covet deaths in
2021 than 2020 even with the vaccine i
mean no student debt relief
now the dude's totally turned his back
on black lives matter all of these
people who advocated for this sold out
their followers burned it to the ground
and now joe biden is just sitting back
yelling shooting on a shot at a pressure
as everything falls apart
it's amazing how easily manipulated we
all are and i think that's you know the
the lesson from the last couple years
with coronavirus and masks and all the
left has been doing is calling someone
racist and then you have to do whatever
they tell you to do and then if not
you're it's like it's not a clever
scheme it's like super
obvious uh or you know you've got to do
this because trump is bad and that's all
they have going for them it's not it's
not clever at all it's not subtle um but
people keep falling for it so what what
would you say the solutions are or what
direction do you believe we have to head
in as a country to fix this
i mean i think we have to the democratic
party really has to reject the illiberal
left i mean these ideas of treating
people differently based on race
rejecting objectivity in some ways like
these are insane ideas
with some of the school stuff where
they're talking about you know getting
into the they got rid of the some of the
math magnet school the top math school
in the country because there weren't
enough blacks getting in so they said
tests are not real like you can't
indulge these ideas that's a conspiracy
theorist there's a conspiracy theory
they call people on the right conspiracy
theorists all the time so i i think the
only people that can save this party joe
this country joe biden was
well situated to do it because he's a
democrat that is not grounded in the far
left fringe and unfortunately we've
learned he's not the guy to do it thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you